Apple's new M3 Max have been available
to order for almost a week now and to my
surprise you can still get every non-max
M3 model on launch day which means that
they're not selling well at all so the
big question is why are people not
ordering these brand new M3 Max well in
this video I'm going to go through the
top 10 reasons or problems that I could
think of to explain what's going on
problem number one is that there are no
design changes at all with these new M3
Maxs including the iMac and the MacBook
Pros you have basically the same display
although they did software boost the
brightness up to 600 nits but we already
knew that there's the Vivid app that
goes up to 1,000 nits which you can
still get in fact the only design change
is the brand new space black color but
you can only get that if you buy the
more expensive M3 Pro and M3 Max models
and with that new color you could
basically just get a Deb brand skin to
make it look space black instead of
spending another $2 to
$4,000 for problem number two it's the
fact that there are no new features at
all we still have the same Notch but
without face ID once again that was
actually one of the things that could
have gotten me to personally upgrade but
no there are no changes to the keyboard
no changes to the speakers the
microphones all of the features no
changes at all and the is is that people
like to see new features when they
upgrade like let's say more ports or
faster ports but no nothing changed at
all for problem number three we have the
price of the M3 base model MacBook Pro
getting more expensive from
$1,300 on the M2 MacBook Pro to
$1600 now yes Apple did increase the
storage to 512 gigs at the base price
which is awesome however there people
out there that are literally buying
Chromebooks that cost $300 this new
$1600 price tag could be pushing A lot
of users to just buy the much less
expensive MacBook Air models like for
example the M1 MacBook ear that you can
get right now on Amazon for
$750 brand new which is a crazy good
deal I'll leave the link down in the
description below for problem number
four the only thing that's really new
with the new M3 iMac and the new M3
MacBook Pros is the brand new chips that
improve the performance and add new
performance features and the problem
with this is that Apple made the M1
family of chips to good as well as the
recent M2 I myself thought of upgrading
to the new M3 Max in space black but I
realized that my current M1 Max 16-in
MacBook Pro is still more than powerful
enough for my workflow flow it just
flies through everything countless
amounts of people have been replying and
saying that their M1 Max are still going
strong doing everything they need so
they have no reason to upgrade so many
people you can see all of these replies
now for problem number five Apple
literally downgraded the M3 Pro chip and
it's blatantly obvious to everyone it's
got the same 12 core CPU but they've
removed two of the important performance
cores to give it two more efficiency
cores instead which are obviously weaker
so the performance is generally the same
overall and then digging even deeper if
you look at the bend M3 pro model that
comes in the 14-in MacBook Pro for
$2,000 it comes with an 11 core CPU with
five performance cores and this is
actually going to be slower than the
previous full unbin M2 Pro with the 12
Cor CPU and8 performance course and same
thing for the graphics the new Bend M3
Pro with the 14 core GPU is going to be
slower than the previous full M2 Pro
with the 19 core GPU even though the new
M3 cores are technically faster you're
losing out on five of them Apple also
downgraded the memory bandwidth to 150
GB per second compared to 200 on the
previous M2 Pro so this is an
embarrassing choice in my view for
problem number six we now have more and
more competition from the windows side
starting to catch up we recently had a
ton of hype from the recent Qualcomm
oron chips including the Snapdragon X
Elite which is actually faster than the
M3 chip now yes it's not faster than the
M3 Max but still it's giving people who
prefer Windows laptops hope for much
faster machines because of the this some
windows users who maybe would have
finally switched to these new M3 MacBook
Pros are holding off to see how good
these new Qualcomm powered laptops are
going to be so the competition is
definitely ramping up for problem number
seven the new M3 Max chip is actually
getting a lot more expensive than before
previously you'd be able to buy the full
M2 Max chip with a 38 core GPU for
$3,500 but now you're actually forced
into upgrading the ram to 48 gigs just
to be able to upgrade the chip to the
full 16 core CPU and 40 core GPU layout
that means that you're spending
$4,000 on a new laptop and this was
actually part of the reason why I didn't
upgrade and why I started thinking about
if my current M1 Max was still good
enough for me to keep for a longer time
so now that apple is making it even more
expensive it's just not as tempting to
upgrade for problem number eight I
believe that Apple made a last minute
choice to release these M3 chip models
sooner than they initially planned due
to their terrible Max sales this last
quarter so they released these just 9
months after the M2 Pro and Max chips so
everybody who was on the fence about
ordering thinks the new ones are going
to come in about 9 to 12 months which
isn't that long to wait so lots of
people are choosing to hold off probably
because of the lack of new features for
problem number nine the truth is that
the economy isn't doing so well more and
more people especially in the tech space
are getting laid off from their work and
it's happening in many different
Industries people's excess savings are
going down interest rates are crazy high
which means that payments on any sort of
debt like mortgage payments car loans
personal loans credit cards are
absolutely going through the roof this
is just too tough of an economy for
people to be buying new devices and it
makes sense why Apple's Mac sales have
been tanking because these Macs are very
expensive and now for problem number 10
there are rumors that apple is working
on some crazy good new OLED displays for
the MacBook Pro and that is making some
people hold off and it's actually the
number one reason why I am holding off
yes the mini LED display on the current
one is great but I hate that it has the
halo effect when I'm watching in movies
so OLED would essentially solve all of
the problems and make it so much better
so personally I see no reason to upgrade
until the actual display gets replaced
with OLED and we of course get much
faster chips and hopefully other
features so there you guys go those were
the top 10 reasons or problems for why I
think people are not buying these new M3
MacBook Pros and iMac so hopefully you
enjoy this video definitely subscribe
above for our testing video starting
tomorrow and check out one of those two
great videos right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
[Music]
video